خيبه امل اصيب بها المستثمرون في تركيا
بعد الاعلان عن نتائج الدوره الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه استطلاعات
الراي التي كانت ترجح فوز المعارضه اعطت
جرعه من الامل للمستثمرين بامكانيه تغير
السياسات الاقتصاديه لتركيا التي عصفت
بالليره وزادت من نسبه التضخم ردوا الفعل
الاولي للسوق على نتائج الانتخابات كان
بتراجع الليره التركيه الى ادنى مستوى لها
في شهرين الى مستوى تسعه عشره فاصل 70
مقابل او مقابل الدولار وهو مستوى غير
بعيد عن تسع عشرات فاصل ثمانيه تحديدا هو
الرقم الذي سجلته العمله التركيه بعد
زلزال فبراير الماضي بشكل عام تراجعت
الليره 5% منذ بدايه العام كما انها فقدت
حوالي 95% من قيمتها على مدار خمسه عشره
عاما الماضيه وكانت موديز للتصنيف
الائتماني قالت الترجيح فوز اردوغان سيعني
استمرار السياسات الاقتصاديه غير
التقليديه ما سيضغط على العمله المحليه
فضلا عن زياده فرص ارتفاع التضخم الذي
تجاوز بالفعل اربعين في المئه معضله اخرى
تواجه تركيا هي العجز الكبير في الحساب
الجاري والذي وصل الى مستوى قياسي بلغ 24
مليار دولار في الربع الاول من هذا العام
مع توقعات بوصوله الى اربعين مليارا
بنهايه العام العجز هذا سيدفع تركيا
لمحاوله العثور على مليارات الدولارات
لتمويل العجز المتزايد ويمكن تحقيق الامر
جزئيا من خلال الاستمرار في الاستفاده من
مخزون تركيا المتضائل من احتياطات العملات
الاجنبيه في هذا السياق الميزانيات
العموميه للدوله والبنك المركزي انخفضت
الى مستويات متدنيه للغايه ما يجعل
احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي للبنك غير
ولتغطيه اي احتياجات لاعاده تمويل النقد
الاجنبي الكبيره للبلاد مثلا محللون
اقتصاديون قالوا لصحيفه فاينشلتاينز
البريطانيه ان تركيا بسياساتها الاقتصاديه
الحاليه ستستمر في السير على حافه الهاويه
وان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في حال حصوله
على ولايه جديده سيكون مضطرا بشكل او باخر
لتغيير سياسته الاقتصاديه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات